hey everybody it's Charlie this is going to
be my full review for infinity war
careful for spoilers if you have not
seen the movie yet because we'll be
talking about very specific things and
there is a new round of that Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway that I'll explain at
the end of the video too so be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I will be doing Avengers 4 videos really
soon - I'm just giving people a little
bit more time to see the movie before we
start on Avengers 4 stuff but since my
non-spoilery review I've had a couple
more chances to see the movie so I've
changed my mind about a couple things
but for the most part the ranking of
this movie in my top 5 Marvel movies
hasn't changed a whole lot so I will
explain why I ranked it the way that I
did so even though Avengers 4 is part
two to this movie they tried to use
infinity war 2 book and a lot of
character arcs because there are just
too many characters to fit them all in
an infinity war which is why there were
some notable absences like ant-man and
Hawkeye like they just didn't bother to
include the ones that weren't critical
for this part of the plot but I think
for all the plot that this movie had to
handle it really did try hard to give
everybody those character moments in a
way that you didn't get those during age
of Ultron so I feel like Infinity Ward
did a really good job of correcting a
lot of the mistakes and the flaws of
Avengers age of Ultron which was mostly
a plot based film at the expense of
character moments so a really good
example of that is the legwork that they
try to do with Scarlet Witch envision
even though we haven't had a whole lot
of their relationship like the last big
scene that we had with them was the
paprika when they were cooking together
that implied that there might be a
relationship with them so you get to
this movie and they're just together
like they just expect you to get that
but they give them some of those deep
character moments before the big twist
at the end of the film we can talk about
the end of the film in a second - but
for every big CG action scene they did
try to give you a really emotional
moment that made you care about what was
happening during all that craziness like
when Thanos was throwing the moon at all
the Avengers in the guardians on Titan
they still tried to get you to a moment
where you cared about what was going on
there instead of just focusing on all
the action it feels like some of the
Black Panther characters were a little
under written you don't really go to
Wakanda to the very end of the film and
when you show up it's bang bang bang
into big battle there's a very few
character moments they tried to give
surety a scene where she sort of
undercut the intelligence of some of the
other Avengers like how come you didn't
think to do this when you were building
vision and we just didn't think of it
it's just a funny moment to show you how
smart she is but the thing about that is
is that it's almost a completely wasted
moment because she doesn't finish the
job they have to take vision away so it
was almost a waste of time like why did
you even do that if this was going to be
the end result he was going to be ripping
it out of his forehead anyway like I
said I think the only reason a couple of
scenes existed was to give people
character moments in we could talk about
Pepper Potts and some of the other
secondary characters Wong was a really
good secondary character like he's in
and out the sanctum is unguarded so I'm
going to go back there see you guys later
and then he just doesn't appear for the
rest of the movie you may have detected
a couple moments during the film where
they were setting up payoffs for
Avengers 4 we call those like teases for
Avengers 4 one of them was Pepper Potts
with Tony where he's talking about
having a child with her
this is them setting up stakes in their
relationship that they'll pay off in
Avengers 4 also did the same thing with
Iron Man and Captain America's character
which is you know we can talk about that
when we get to Avengers 4 predictions
but a lot of that gets into some of the
mechanics of the way they explain how
the Infinity stones work the way you had
to sacrifice someone for the soul gem
but like I said even though this was
like a series of big action scenes
strung together they strung those
together with really good character
moments do you concur doctor all the
Doctor Strange Ironman scenes with one
of my favorite pairings in the film I
think I said it during my non-spoilery
review Thor in the guardians in Iron Man
and Doctor Strange were my two favorite
pairings I think for a lot of the other
relationships because this movie had to
accomplish so much the writers and the
producers hope that you just come into
it knowing how certain characters work
and what the pre-existing relationships
are you don't have to give every single
character a really long scene re
explaining what their relationship with
each other is so like Winter Soldier in
Captain America don't spend that long
getting back together it's just like hey
man how you been you just see them do
that and you get it so that was also
kind of the same thing with spider-man
in Iron Man so that at the end of the
film you get that emotional turn Tom
Hollands performance in that final scene
his doctor
who moment I don't want to go probably
the most emotional ash person of them
all not the most emotional death I still
give that to Thanos and Gomorrah because
Josh Brolin's performance was fantastic
in the way they redesigned Thanos his
face look if you go back and you watch
that original Avengers film look at the
Thanos post-credits scene it looks
laughable compared to how good the nose
looks in Avengers infinity war so you
can tell they've been working on getting
the textures of his face just making it
look more human-like so that when he
cries you can actually tell what's going
on and you get that you see the emotion
on Josh Brolin's face underneath the
motion capture
they've even nailed some of the
nonverbal reactions to like when Thanos
smirks or when he narrows his eyes like
just little tics of Josh Brolin's face
the things that you see Robert Downey
jr. doing a lot like when he's looking
at spider-man like oh come on kid he
doesn't have to say that you just read
it on his face so of all the motion
capture characters Thanos was the best
which was important for the film because
this was really Thanos his film that was
a bit of a cheat at the marketing
although to be fair the Russos did tell
us that this was a Knossos movie but
then you kind of see how he gets this
full arc during infinity war it's really
about Thanos's arc completing the
gauntlet he snaps his fingers he
accomplishes his mission what does that
mean for his role during Avengers 4
there are a lot of unresolved arcs for
the Avengers because Doctor Strange says
this was the only way the only way we
could win the one plan that they could
undertake in millions of possibilities
that he foresaw that would lead them to
victory
losing the initial battle so that they
could win the war what does that say
about Thanos during Avengers 4 is he
even going to be a main character they have to get the gauntlet from him but I think
that's why Kevin Feige in the Russos
changed the title of Avengers 4-2
untitled and it's going to be something
different because infinity war is
Stannis's arc from start to finish he
has nothing more to do like he's
chilling out on what looks like gamora's
planet which he said had become a
paradise since he destroyed half of all
life they're just sort of marveling at
his accomplishment I'm happy I can
finally relax and enjoy myself
that's them telling you that he's done
he has nothing more left to do I think
the reason that a lot of the mainstream
media knocked the movie down a little
bit is some of the table setting
that they did in addition to that so
there's all these strings in the
background to like you have to setup all
the Avengers arts this big tease of dr.
Strange's his secret plan with Iron Man
we're going to lose this battle so that we
can win the war in pursuit of that there
are a lot of cheats that the movie just
expects you to be on board with which I
was totally fine with but it's kind of
funny the second or third time you see
the movie you pick up on those things a
little bit more like scarlet witch's
accent this is what she sounded like
during age of Ultron when she first
debuted but I saw Starks fear I knew it
with control him make him self-destruct
during Captain America Civil War she
still kind of had that accent a little
bit but then during infinity war the
funny thing you may have noticed is that
she doesn't have an accent at all it's
almost like they just decided to drop it
like you know what who cares let's not
do the accent it's kind of weird anyway
and then I know a lot of people were
also disappointed with the Hulk what was
the deal with the Hulk not being able to
Hulk out I think that was mostly in
favor of giving Ruffalo performance
because you just did a big movie with
him being hoped for most of that so they
wanted to give you a lot of Ruffalo and
hold back Hulk for Avengers 4 so they
just kind of asked you to be on board
with some of these funny cheats like oh
you know what you can always be the Hulk
except now he doesn't want to be the
Hulk the Hulk won't let him be the Hulk
which doesn't totally make sense they'll
probably be some silly explainer for it
during Avengers 4 like the Hulk is
afraid of Thanos or something like that
I haven't changed my mind about some of
the things that I think did not work
like the Black Order for instance some
of the CG just wasn't great
evany maw was amazing of all the black
order he was definitely my favorite the
Russos even said before the movie came
out that he had become an early fan
favorite but Proxima midnight SMO ssin
capture was not good at all Carrie Coon
the actress that was doing the voice for
her is an amazing actress but for
whatever reason the motion capture just
was not on point
my other mild disappointment was Peter
Dinklage's character he's amazing he's a
great actor but I just felt like what
they did with that character wasn't that
great they didn't write him that well
and it wound up taking me out of the
movie a little bit even though all the
stuff that they did there the forging of
Stormbreaker all that stuff was great I
just feel like the stuff that they did
with Peter Dinklage's character could
a little bit better loved all the Gamora
Thanos scenes you really do feel like
they cared and loved each other despite
their relationship like Gamora says I
hate you you're terrible but she still
cries for him the first time she thought
that she killed him
so I know there's a lot of questions
about everything that happened relative
to the soul gem what's going on with the
Red Skull surprise that's actually not
Hugo Weaving underneath that motion
capture its Ross Marquand from The
Walking Dead
that's why his voice sounded a little
bit different and I know there's all
kinds of questions about the soul world
and where Thanos went when he snapped
his fingers at the end of the film so
that's like a separate video there's
more Avengers for teaser related stuff
getting into the mechanics of how the
Infinity stones work but don't worry
just be thinking soul world something's
still alive inside the soul gem I think
for the most part they did earn their
ending where everyone turns to ash like
I said this was meant to be the
culmination of Thanos arc his goal was
to snap his fingers in a race half of
all life so they reminded you of that at
least like three times during the film
they kept referring to him snapping his
fingers and so of course he was going to
snap his fingers at the end but you do
kind of have to laugh if you follow a
lot of these movies you can kind of see
the table setting they're doing so
they're wiping a lot of characters
literally wiping them off the board so
that there are fewer characters to deal
with in Avengers 4 and going to be a little
bit more personal and they can bring
characters off the bench like ant-man
and Hawkeye and Captain Marvel now so I
think a lot of the mainstream media is
knocking the movie for being very
obvious about that like they wiped Black
Panther away we know he's getting a
sequel so you know he's coming back you
know spider-man is coming back because
they're filming spider-man 2 this summer
so there are a couple big comic book
movie moments that you just asked to
accept like okay yeah we know they're
coming back we know how this works but
they still earn those emotional turns
you still cry a little bit when
Spiderman says I don't want to go mr.
stark but of course some of my next
couple of videos will be explaining some
of the bigger twists the mechanics of
the soul gem why I think the soul world
is a very important thing in why I think
the Captain America is going to be the
person that Iron Man has to sacrifice to
wield the Infinity Gauntlet in Avengers
4 so I will say after they explained
Gamora in half an
had a sacrificer Captain America shot to
the top of my death predictions list for
Avengers 4 because if they're going to fix
the universe they have to wield the soul
gem amongst the other gems meaning that
whoever wields that gauntlet has to
sacrifice someone to the soul gem in
because of the parallels between Tony
and Thanos's arcs I too have had visions
of you Stark Thanos saw Starks so
they're putting them on this parallel
arc so if Thanos wore the gauntlet in
this movie that is probably going to be
Tony to wear the gauntlet and Avengers 4
but just be thinking about that don't
worry those videos will post over the
course of the weekend leave all your
requests in the comments below and
you're all asking where I rank this now
in my top 5 Marvel films so Winter
Soldier is still my favorite but
infinity war is now my second favorite
close second then Black Panther then the
original Iron Man film still holds up
still an amazing film then Captain
America Civil War so for the most part
pretty quality all around but these are
just my top 5 this stand above the rest
right now big question for you guys
though where do you rank infinity war in
your list of favorite Marvel films now
this is a new round of the Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video congratulations
to the winner from my last video Michael
Bradley please private message me so I
can get your contact details click here
for my post credit scene video and click
here for that other new Deadpool trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome we'll see you guys tonight!